welcome back to las vegas now one local
company is providing quality in-home lab
services for patients all you need
is an order form from your doctor and
owner ashley will be at your door with a
smile and all the supplies
hello my name is ashley with sunrise
pathology services i'm here for an
appointment
we are a mobile phlebotomy business that
services the area of las vegas
the reason why a patient would need
phlebotomy
services altogether is to be able to
start
the process of figuring out what is
exactly wrong
with the patient answers
come from the blood work so it's really
important we play
a big part in getting the process
and the ball rolling for the physicians
to be able to know how to treat their
patients
in their care for myself being a working
mom of two and also working full time
while branding my business
it is really hard to focus on yourself
and to be able to get into
the doctors alone just for an
appointment and so
when patients are neglecting their
health when it hits them it hits them
really
hard and so if you just don't have the
time to be able to go out to the doctors
or
to sit in a patient-centered service for
a long time
you know your your health is going to
decline and work here to make sure that
the patient has
more options to choose themselves and
their health first
and so we will come directly to you get
your samples and take them to the labs
ourselves so that you don't have to step
outside of your house or we can draw you
at work and so it's les it's more
convenient for the patient
sunrise pathology services we offer
routine blood work stat blood work
we also offer early gender dna detection
with our
partners as long as you're seven weeks
or more pregnant we are able to let you
know what you're having within one to
two business days
we also are able to do um
for family tree if you want to know more
about your history we're able to do that
as well and so what we do is
if a patient wants to schedule an
appointment
we will create the appointment for the
patient ask for the requisition which is
a doctor's order to let us know
why that patient is being tested so we
make sure we have the right supplies
we will then go to the appointment for
the patient collect their blood samples
process and drop off the samples to the
laboratory choice
which the insurance does cover once you
receive your lab order from your
physician i encourage you to visit
sunrisepathologyservices.com
to book an appointment with us there is
a service fee it's a draw fee of fifty
dollars
and your insurance covers the rest they
pay the laboratory for
the specimen processing we have a
special offer for the community
with ornament if you download it you get
one free month
of service using the promo code
pathology 2021
this app interprets and visualizes your
lab orders results
that is so great and she was a
sweetheart sunrise pathology services
give
ashley a call at 725-243-4242
or visit sunrisepathologyservices.com
and remember that special offer
you can get a free month on the ornament
app with labs using code pathology2021
we'll be right back